ahora hagamos la comparación de
eliminación contra sustitución para un
sustrato terciario en esta reacción
tenemos una luro de alquilo terciario y
sabemos que un alumno de alquilo
terciario forma un kart vocación
terciario que es un kart vocación
estable por lo tanto una reacción es cn
uno si es posible pero una reacción sn 2
no es posible porque en un alumno de
alquilo terciario hay mucho impedimento
estético mientras que un mecanismo 1 si
es posible porque un mecanismo 1
necesita un kart vocación estable y un
mecanismo 2 también es posible entonces
tenemos tres posibles opciones para un
sustrato terciario pero analicemos el
reactivo
aquí tenemos cloruro de sodio y sabemos
que el ión cloruro es una base muy débil
y sólo funcionará como un núcleo filo
entonces como aquí tenemos un núcleo
filo ocurre una reacción de sustitución
así que para este caso debe de ser la
reacción s
y sabemos que en un mecanismo sn 1 el
primer paso es la pérdida del grupo
saliente con lo que en este caso se
forma el año en yoduro y como le
quitamos un enlace a este carbono de
color rojo formamos un kart vocación
terciario vamos a dibujar aquí tenemos
nuestro anillo de 6 miembros y aquí
tenemos el grupo metilo y el carbono
rojo es este carbono que ahora tiene una
carga formal positiva ok y una vez que
formamos nuestro carbó catión en el
siguiente paso del mecanismo el núcleo
fi lo ataca y en este caso el núcleo
filo es el ión cloruro entonces un par
de electrones libres en el cloro forman
un enlace con ese carbono de color rojo
y así obtenemos nuestro producto
entonces aquí tenemos el anillo por acá
tenemos un grupo metilo y ahora tenemos
un enlace con el cloro entonces este par
de electrones libres de color rosa
formaron este enlace entre el cloro y el
carbono rojo y como no hay exterior
química no tenemos que preocuparnos por
eso porque no tenemos ningún centro que
ir al entonces este fue un mecanismo sn
primero analicemos el sustrato podemos
ver que este es un alumno de alquilo
terciario el carbono que está unido
directamente a nuestro halógeno está
unido a otros 3 carbonos así que una
luro de alquilo terciario tiene tanto
impedimento estético que no puede
ocurrir una reacción sn dos así que
queda fuera y cuando analizamos el
reactivo en este caso tenemos tributó
óxido de potasio entonces déjenme
dibujar la estructura tenemos una carga
formal negativa en este oxígeno y el
potasio tiene una carga positiva y miren
el tributo óxido de potasio tiene tanto
impedimento estético que no puede actuar
como un núcleo filo por lo que la
reacción es cn uno
queda fuera y como el termo tóxico de
potasio es una base fuerte la reacción
de uno también queda fuera lo que nos
deja con el mecanismo de reacción es 2
entonces dibujemos nuevamente el allure
o de alquilo sabemos que el carbono que
está unido al halógeno es el carbono
alfa y los carbonos beta son los que
están unidos a ese carbono entonces este
es un carbono beta este es un carbono
beta y este es un carbono beta y
supongamos que entra a nuestra base
fuerte con impedimento estético y toma
un protón de este carbono beta entonces
nuestra base toma este protón con lo que
estos electrones se mueven hacia acá al
mismo tiempo que estos electrones se van
junto con el bromo para formar el año en
bromuro y así es cómo obtenemos un
producto en esta reacción
y ahora tenemos un doble enlace ok
resaltemos los electrones los electrones
de color rosa se movieron para formar el
doble enlace pero ahora supongamos que
tomamos un protón de un carbono beta
diferente entonces vamos a redibujar
esto aquí tenemos el alumno de alquilo y
nuevamente este es el carbono alfa pero
ahora tomaremos un protón de este
carbono beta
entonces pongamos el protón y aquí
tenemos nuestra base con su carga
negativa esta base toma este protón con
lo que estos electrones se mueven aquí
al mismo tiempo que estos electrones se
van junto con el bromo ese es nuestro
mecanismo 2 dibujemos el al que no que
nos queda esta vez el doble enlace se
encuentra aquí y los electrones de color
rosa se movieron hacia acá para formar
el doble enlace entonces si analizamos
los dos productos
sabemos que el producto de la derecha
más estable porque es un el que nutre y
sustituido mientras que el de la
izquierda es un al que no de sustituido
pero cuando nos enfocamos en la base el
tributo óxido de potasio resulta que él
al que no menos sustituido es el
producto mayor y eso es porque la base
tiene mucho impedimento estético y bueno
también observen que si la base entra y
toma un protón de este carbono beta
obtenemos el mismo producto que tenemos
aquí aquí tenemos otro sustrato
terciario así que el mecanismo sn 2
queda fuera y cuando analizamos el
reactivo que en este caso es el met
óxido de sodio
sabemos que el sodio tiene una carga
formal positiva y que el oxígeno tiene
una carga formal negativa y en algún
vídeo anterior vimos que el ión met
óxido es un núcleo filo fuerte y una
base fuerte y si pensamos en una base
fuerte podemos pensar en una reacción 2
esa es la reacción dominante aquí y una
reacción de 2
significa que el ión met óxido funciona
como una base y toma un protón del
allure o de alquilo entonces analicemos
el allure o de alc y lo vamos a ver el
carbono unido a nuestro halógeno es el
carbono alfa y los carbonos unidos
directamente al carbono alfa son los
carbonos beta y en este caso los
carbonos beta son iguales entonces
digamos que este es nuestro carbono beta
y vamos a dibujar un hidrógeno y ahora
el guión me tóxico entra vamos a
dibujarlo aquí tenemos una carga formal
negativa en el oxígeno y un par de
electrones en el oxígeno toma este
protón al mismo tiempo que estos
electrones se mueven hacia acá para
formar el doble enlace y estos
electrones se van con el yodo para
formar el ión yoduro como grupo saliente
entonces en el producto final aquí
tenemos un doble enlace
y estos electrones de color rosa se
movieron hacia acá para formar el doble
enlace y como en este caso todos los
carbonos beta son iguales este es el
único producto de esta reacción aquí
tenemos el mismo haluro de alquilo
terciario que vimos en el problema
anterior así que una reacción sn 2 queda
fuera y cuando analizamos el reactivo
sabemos que el agua es un núcleo filo
débil y una base débil entonces si el
agua es una base débil la reacción de
dos queda fuera y eso nos deja con la
reacción de una ola sn 1 porque en las
dos se forma un carbó catión vamos a ver
estos electrones se van con el yodo para
formar el ión yoduro y le quitamos un
enlace al carbono de color rojo con lo
que se forma un kart vocación terciario
vamos a dibujarlo entonces nuestro carbó
catión terciario tiene una carga formal
positiva en el carbono central es
en este carbono de color rojo y si el
agua actúa como una base débil puede
tomar un protón de uno de los carbonos
que se encuentran cerca del carbono rojo
entonces si dibujamos un hidrógeno en
este carbono el agua toma ese protón con
lo que estos electrones se mueven hacia
acá para formar un doble enlace ese es
uno de los posibles productos que
podemos obtener en esta reacción
formamos un al que no y los electrones
de color rosa se movieron hacia acá para
formar el doble enlace ok eso es lo que
pasa cuando el agua actúa como una base
débil y ese sería el mecanismo e1 pero
también tenemos la posibilidad de un
mecanismo sn uno entonces dibujemos
nuevamente nuestro carbó cateo aquí
tenemos nuestro carbó catión y el
carbono de color rojo es este carbono
que tiene una carga formal positiva pero
esta vez el agua actuará como un núcleo
fila
hemos la molécula de agua tiene dos
pares de electrones libres en el oxígeno
entonces el núcleo fi lo ataca al
electro filo y formamos un enlace entre
el oxígeno y el carbono rojo vamos a
dibujar ahora tenemos un enlace entre el
oxígeno y el carbono rojo que es este
carbono entonces un par de electrones
libres en el oxígeno formaron este
enlace y el oxígeno aún está unido a
otros dos hidrógenos y tiene un par de
electrones libres todo eso le da al
oxígeno una carga formal positiva así
que en el siguiente paso ocurre una
reacción ácido base otra molécula de
agua entra y toma uno de esos protones
pero para notar darnos mucho en este
vídeo
solamente escribiré menos h más perdemos
un protón y formamos el producto que en
este caso es un alcohol terciario
entonces en esta reacción existen dos
habilidades tanto puede ocurrir una
reacción a uno con lo que obtenemos este
al que no o puede ocurrir una reacción
sn 1 con lo que obtenemos este alcohol
para el último ejemplo veamos este
alcohol terciario sabemos que la
reacción sn 2 queda fuera y como tenemos
un ácido fuerte y no una base fuerte la
reacción de dos también queda fuera y
siempre que tenemos un alcohol terciario
con algo como el ácido sulfúrico o el
ácido fosfórico y calor podemos pensar
en una reacción en uno entonces aquí
necesitamos formar un carbó catión pero
antes de eso analicemos la estructura de
nuestro alcohol
miren el carbono unido a lo h es nuestro
carbono alfa y los carbonos unidos
directamente a ese son los carbonos beta
entonces aquí tenemos al carbono beta 1
beta 2 y es
es el beta 3 pero no podemos deshacernos
del grupo saliente nada más así porque
el ión hidróxido es un mal grupo
saliente pero nuestro ácido sulfúrico es
una fuente de protones así que el primer
paso es la protón acción del alcohol un
par de electrones libres en el oxígeno
toman este protón dibujemos lo que se
forma ahora el oxígeno está unido a dos
hidrógenos y también tiene un par de
electrones libres y una carga formal
positiva ok entonces estos electrones de
color rosa tomaron este protón para
formar este enlace ahora sí ya estamos
listos para la pérdida del grupo
saliente entonces cuando estos
electrones se van junto con el oxígeno
obtenemos agua que sabemos que es una
molécula estable es un buen grupo
saliente y como le quitamos un enlace a
este carbono rojo formamos un kart
vocación entonces dibujemos nuestro
carbó catión y
aquí tenemos el grupo metilo ok entonces
el carbono de color rojo es este carbono
aquí es en donde tenemos una carga
formal positiva y sabemos que en el
mecanismo uno entra a una base débil y
toma un protón de uno de los carbonos
beta entonces si nos vamos con el
carbono beta 3 del carbó catión vamos a
dibujar uno de los hidrógenos este
carbono de color azul es este carbono y
nuestro alcohol inicial así que a una
base débil debe de ser el agua porque
formamos agua en el paso anterior
entonces el agua entra y toma ese protón
dibujemos el par de electrones libres
entonces tomamos este protón con lo que
estos electrones se mueven hacia acá
para formar un doble enlace y claro con
eso nos deshacemos de la carga formal en
el carbono rojo y así obtenemos nuestro
producto que en este caso es un al que
ahí está entonces los electrones de
color rosa
se movieron hacia acá para formar el
doble enlace y así es como obtenemos un
al que no trees sustituido y que pasa si
tomamos un protón de uno de los otros
carbonos beta bueno si regresamos al
alcohol terciario podemos ver que el
carbono beta 1 y beta 2 nos dan el mismo
producto así que solo tomamos un
entonces primero re dibujemos el carb
ocasión terciario ahí está y tenemos una
carga formal positiva en el carbono rojo
pero ahora vamos a dibujar uno de los
hidrógenos que tenemos en este carbono
entonces el agua funcionará como una
base vamos a dibujar la molécula de agua
y toma este protón con lo que estos
electrones se mueven hacia acá para
formar el doble enlace entonces si
dibujamos nuestro producto ahora tenemos
un doble enlace aquí y los electrones de
color rosa se movieron hacia acá para
formar el doble enlace
y este es solamente un al que no de
sustituido por lo que será el producto
menor y el producto mayor es el al que
no 3 sustituido porque es el más estable
entonces este es el producto mayor de
nuestra reacción e1